drablan sur les étalages de cigarettes
ce matin dans ce bar de moropa un signe
de protestation contre un projet de loi
européen visant à obliger l'industrie du
tabac à commercialiser des paquets
neutres sans marque sans logo mais avec
des images choc plus grandes
parallèlement à cette mesure le
gouvernement a annoncé une nouvelle
hausse de 6 % du prix du tabac pour
Jean-François vigourou patron de
l'établissement sen est trop on nous
fait passer pour des marchands de mort
ces humiliations pour les fumeurs je
pense qu'il y a autre chose à faire que
de nous empêcher de travailler et pour
nous la première des premier des
problèmes pour les buralistes c'est la
contrebande il faut savoir que elle
représente plus de 20 % de du marché
donc c'est-à-dire que quand on vend
quatre paquets il y a un paquet qui est
vendu à l'extérieur du réseau
Jean-François vigourou reconnaît qu'il y
a un véritable problème de santé
publique en France mais selon lui et la
dizaine de buralistestive Linois en
colère rassemblé ce matin augmenter les
prix et changer le format des paquets
est une fausse solution Antonio Gomez
est également buraliste à Mor repas à
chaque nouvelle hausse du prix du tabac
il perd des clients si les choses
continuent dans ce sens il se verra dans
l'obligation de diversifier son activité
ù je vais faire je vais essayer de faire
restauration mais il y a des
accconpagignants aussi ou
je sais pas si on peut vendre d'autres
d'autres articles je me suis pas encore
bien posé la question mais bon il va
falloir trouver une solution en tout cas
malgré les campagnes publicitaires
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics ou encore la hausse du prix des
cigarettes une de l'INPES rapporte que
la part de fumeurs régulier âgé de 15 à
75 ans a augmenté de 2 points entre 2005
et 2010 rappelons que le tabac est le
principal facteur de risque du
cancer